kindesmissbrauch horrorzahlen die
schockieren 30.000 verdächtige allein im
missbrauchsskandal von bergisch gladbach
terabyte an videomaterial werden
ausgetauscht
erschreckend manche täter vergehen sich
an den eigenen kindern teilweise im
säuglingsalter
mir wurde bei diesen zahlen war übel
das ist ein einziger komplex die sind
nicht nur im darknet die sind auch im
ganz normal internet und selbst in den
messager gruppen mit denen wir alle
umgehen
völlig ohne sorgen völlig sorgenfrei die
ermittler frustriert kaum eine chance
die täter zu fassen
im fall bergisch gladbach kam der
hinweis aus kanada
da gibt es andere datenschutzgesetze ich
liebe kinder
ein spielplatz in berlin ein mann
schnappt sich ein zweijähriges mädchen
und läuft los weil eine aufmerksame
mutter eingreift wird er verhaftet
am abend ist er wieder frei keine
fluchtgefahr
wer schützt endlich unsere kinder da
sind bilder die erschreckend sind
meldungen die man einfach gar nicht
hören möchte was das geht euch was geht
ihnen durch den kopf
ja es kann einem speiübel werden also
was die dimensionen an geht vor allem
auch ich meine dass aufklärung
nachhinein ist wichtig aber noch viel
wichtiger wäre eigentlich wenn man es im
vorhinein hätte verhindern können
zumindest diese dimension
und wir haben ja immer wieder fälle also
vieles findet ihr auch in familien statt
und oder zumindest im nahbereich und da
frage ich mich schon können wir nicht
jugendämter so ausstatten auch mit mehr
personal das sie einfach genauer
hingucken bei vielen fällen war es ja
wirklich nicht ganz ungewöhnlich tanz
unabsehbar es gab ja fälle ein junge der
wurde missbraucht
von dem stiefvater der junge wurde nie
gefragt vorher müsse es dann wirklich
viel zu spät war
und da finde ich dann da muss der erste
schritt sein und das zweite ist dann
wenn man es nicht verhindern konnte
wenigstens die zur rechenschaft zu
ziehen und auch wirklich zu verurteilen
die so was machen aber auch der aktuelle
fall in berlin
patricia du bist auch mal war so wie ich
auch und da überlegt man das kann doch
nicht sein weil die mutter und tochter
die kriegen ab dem moment wo es passiert
kriegen die lebenslänglich
und der tätern cannavaro genau das muss
man sagen also es ist für mich als
mutter als mensch ist es schwer
nachvollziehbar dass jemand der ein kind
von einem spielplatz mit nimmt der
polizei bekannt ist dass er jetzt frei
rumläuft und mir macht das angst und
bange
so ist jeder ist am spielplatz mal kurz
abgelenkt gott sei dank gab es in diesem
fall so viel zivilcourage dass eine
mutter eingegriffen hat dass ein mann
ihr noch geholfen hat dass wir dort auch
reagiert haben und da sehe ich uns auch
alle in der verantwortung ich glaube
dass wir manchmal eine mischung von zu
ängstlich zu faul zu ich möchte mich
nicht ein das geht nicht geht mich
nichts an sind also auch da sind wir
finde ich als gesellschaft gefragt
hinzuschauen und lieber einmal zu viel
einmischen ja wickel wieder nach
entschuldigen ich glaube dass auch ganz
viel angst dabei wenn es um zivilcourage
geht neben sinne von also nicht dass es
eine entschuldigung sein soll aber
könnte mir jetzt etwas passieren mische
ich mich in etwas ein und ich liege
falsch und wenn dann der buhmann
ich finde genau da müsse man auch mit
der aufklärung was ist zivilcourage wo
fängt das an das müsste eigentlich
theoretisch ein schulfach sein ich
glaube dass es aber auch und da wird
einem speiübel ist ja wie sozusagen auch
von rechtswegen damit umgegangen wird
also die tatsache dass es tatsächlich
immer noch als vergehen bezeichnet wird
also man muss sich ja mal
vergegenwärtigen gesetze werden von
menschen gemacht das heißt diese
menschen die diese gesetze gemacht haben
für die sozusagen die der missbrauch und
die vergewaltigung von kindern ein
vergehen und kein verbrechen
und das ist etwas finde ich wo wir
ansetzen müssen und wir müssen
eigentlich noch viel mehr konkretisieren
was da genau passiert also das hat für
mich auch nichts mit missbrauch zu tun
sondern das ist körperliche gewalt die
angewandt wird ich sag's mal einfach wie
es ist wirklich oral an
wir reden von kleinen kindern im alter
von fünf sechs sieben man kann jährigen
retten also ich habe ja auch mit
vergewaltigungsopfern zu tun und ich hab
mal mit einem beamten darüber geredet
der mir etwas gesagt hat was ich
eigentlich nie wieder vergessen habe der
auch dafür zuständig war oder hat gesagt
wenn dieses material ausgewertet hat das
was er nie vergessen konnte und was ihn
immer wieder den schlaf verfolgt hat war
der blick der kinder und ich weiß dass
es weh tut das so auszusprechen
aber ich möchte damit auch erreichen und
ich glaube da spreche ich im namen von
uns allen dass endlich auch verstanden
wird dass das ein verbrechen ist und
kein vergehen und dass wir gesetze
brauchen die das ahnten aber jetzt in
die bundesjustizministerin christine
lambrecht hat sich dazu geäußert darauf
werden wir natürlich auch gleich noch
mal eingehen weil er gibt es ja oder
soll es änderungen geben
ich muss jetzt aber pharma sie hier bei
uns in der sendung sind sind aus der
politik sie sind eine spitzenfrau der
politik ich frag mich immer als ja als
einfache frau frage ich mich warum
dauert das so lange warum muss man
soviel passieren meint 30.000
verdächtige in meinem fall ja und man
muss sagen selbst das wäre vielleicht
jetzt immer noch nicht aufgedeckt worden
wenn nrw nicht wesentlich mehr personal
eingestellt hätte die haben ja nach
diesem furchtbaren vorfällen auf diesem
campingplatz tatsächlich endlich mal
ihre personaldecke deutlich erhöht also
mehr beamte eingestellt mehr beamte auch
ganz konkret auch technisch ausgerüstet
und dadurch haben sie das überhaupt
aufdecken können und ich finde das zeigt
uns wirklich
es wird ja immer gleich gesagt
gesetzesverschärfung ich finde es jetzt
richtig dass das verbrechen sind und
keine vergehen
aber es müssen alle gesetzesverschärfung
gar nichts wenn die gesetze nicht
eingehalten werden weil die täter sich
relativ sicher sein können dass sie
nicht entdeckt werden
und wenn man das ändern will braucht man
mehr personal auch mehr technische
ausstattung in den ämtern und mehr
möglichkeiten auch zu ermitteln und ich
finde das ist das wo wir jetzt wirklich
auch ganz dringend etwas ändern müssen
eben nicht nur in nrw und dann wird sich
auch gleich vertriebsseite ausgleich zu
schiessen wir wollen es ganz kurz
anschauen was christine lambrecht gesagt
hat die bundesjury
bundesjustizministerin entschuldigung
bitte schön
mir ist es wichtig dass wir dieses thema
so ist es so wichtige thema nicht nur
reduzieren auf strafverschärfungen
sondern dass wir unsere verantwortung
den kindern gegenüber annehmen in bezug
auf prävention in bezug auf stärkung der
ermittlungsarbeit und auch in bezug auf
strafen die das unrecht der tat auch
abbilden und in dieser gesamtheit möchte
ich es sehen und so habe ich mich auch
geäußert so exklusiv hat sie das der
bild gesagt was sagen wir dazu heute
gerade einmal eineinhalb natürlich ist
es wichtig auch dass er auf landesebene
und für die enter viel passieren muss
dass wir als gesellschaft oft sind ich
bin aber schon sehr froh dass wir da
jetzt auch gesetze angehen denn ganz
klar ich möchte wenn jemand sich
kinderpornos ansieht muss das strafbar
für mich sein
ich kann es nicht nachvollziehen dass es
nicht strafbar aber ich kann
bewährungsstrafen in diesem fall nicht
nachvollziehen
ich finde wenn wir da nicht er denkt ich
kann nicht nachvollziehen dass dieser
mann von dem spielplatz immer noch frei
herumläuft und eine bedrohung für kinder
ist und da helfen uns ich direkt in der
prävention wahrscheinlich machen diese
menschen es dann trotzdem
ich möchte aber wenn sie so etwas machen
dass sie hart bestraft werden
aber ich finde ich finde dieses
überhaupt das diskutiert wird sollte man
eventuell jetzt so eine harte strafe
oder so ich bin da muss ich sah wirklich
komplett rigoros und sagt ich bin
komplett für die meldepflicht ich will
ich will es wissen wenn so jemand in
meiner nachbarschaft und ich glaube auch
nicht dass er eventuell längere
gefängnisstrafen vielleicht geldstrafen
was auch immer dass das irgendwie
abschreckte bin ich der meinung das wird
nicht funktionieren man muss ihn die
öffentlichkeit zerren muss eine
meldepflicht festlegen und dann ist das
ding also höher geht es gar nicht in dem
moment was halten sie davon frau wann
ich eine mail anhänge auf jeden fall
dass diejenigen die so was machen also
die aktiv dabei sind also wirklich
extrem harte strafen bekommen müssen und
sie müssen und ich glaube das ist dann
schon eine abschreckung wirklich auch
angst haben dass sie dabei erwischt
werden weil ich glaube dass ist der
hauptgrund also das ist schon etwas was
viele leute auch leichtfertig einmal
selbst im normalen und im internet damit
umgehen lässt weil sie offensichtlich
davon ausgehen sie werden überhaupt
nicht erwischt es passiere nichts und
dann erst nützen auch die harten gesetze
etwas wenn sie wirklich die angst haben
müssen dass trifft sie dann auch und das
ist also ich finde das sind wirklich mit
die schlimmsten verbrechen die es gibt
weil man damit kindern eigentlich das
leben zerstört also so wie sie gesagt
haben das ist lebenslänglich das
vergisst man nie und deswegen ist
tatsächlich hier alles zu tun die
verantwortlichen zur rechenschaft zu
ziehen aber ich würde mir eben auch
wünschen dass wir es öfter schaffen es
viel früher zu merken also wirklich
gleich einzugreifen wenn
familienverhältnisse so sind dass man
damit rechnen muss dass vielleicht schon
einer das war ja in dem einen fall so
der war schon verurteilt wegen eines
solchen delikts
nun ist es so klar in einem rechtsstaat
wenn eine strafe abgesessen ist hat
jemand auch wenn er die schlimmsten
sachen gemacht hat
noch mal die chance erleben normal zu
führen aber man muss zumindest genau
hingucken und wenn irgend wie es den
verdacht hat also muss man zum beispiel
das kind befragen also um dazu wissen
und darf nicht lange zeit erst
verstreichen lassen und zu schauen und
und da finden die schlimmsten dinge
statt und ich mache mir auch große
sorgen jetzt in diesem lockdown also in
dem frühjahr es ist ja nicht nur im
internet so dass die bilder mehr
geworden sind sondern es sind ja ganz
offensichtlich auch die fälle mehr
geworden und das wird viel zu wenig
finde ich auch debattiert was das für
auswirkungen hat wie viel kinder jetzt
möglicherweise wirklich schlimmes
erlitten haben und was wir mehr dagegen
tun können also ja schon von der anderen
seite wir sind präventive auch arbeiten
dass man das wirklich auch in kitas und
schulen art aufklärungsunterricht auch
gestaltet was ist okay was ist nicht
okay und dass man das auch wirklich
beigebracht bekommt die ich genauso
wenig hinter zählt das wahrscheinlich
nicht direkt aber es gibt sicherlich
psychologische indikatoren wo man sagen
da muss man jetzt mal genauer hingucken
wenn das kind so was sagt oder sowas
malt oder irgendwie dinge tut ich bin ja
auch kein psychologe an denen man
vielleicht ablesen kann
da ist möglicherweise etwas da muss man
noch mal ganz genau hingucken was da
wirklich passiert und gesetzt haben ja
auch was mit werte und normen zu tun und
es geht darum dass man das
gesellschaftlich ächtet also ich meine
es gibt ein beispiel bei frauen in der
schwangerschaft die früher vielleicht
weniger alkohol getrunken haben zum
beispiel weil das gesellschaftlich auch
irgendwie akzeptiert wurden ja das würde
heute kaum noch vorkommen weil deine
ganze zivilgesellschaft sozusagen
dagegen ist und ich glaube diese ächtung
die muss sozusagen aus allen ebenen
heraus erfolgen aber vor allem brauchen
wir dafür die richtigen gesetze die dann
auch adäquat angewandt werden
[Musik]